hi I'm Eric Boston it chapter 2 released
a haunting trailer following up the
first chapter of the 2017 reboot with
perfectly cast adult versions of the
losers Club and evoking everyone's
greatest fear roommates forgetting to
bring a towel when they shower both
Stephen King's original novel and Andy
machetes remake works so well largely
because these movies and trailers
themselves be haunted with subtle visual
details that are easy to overlook but
then when you spot them you'll wet
yourself all over again so I'm gonna
break down this trailer shot-for-shot
for everything that you might have
missed and what to expect in this movie
now I will elude the sum of what happens
in the second half of Stephen King's
novel because folks it's been out for 33
years but I guess I'll avoid the big
twist just in case some of you haven't
read the book but just to be safe
spoiler warning if you haven't read it
let's get started yeah I used to live
here is it like you remember cleaner
well you feel free to look around while
I get the water boil in okay this
trailer opens with adult Beverly Marsh
visiting her old home Bev is now a
fashion designer in Chicago she's played
by Jessica Chastain and this is really a
dream cast shortly after the first movie
came out they asked the kids which
actors they wanted to play their older
selves and young Beth Sophia Lilith
actually named Chastain as her ideal
choice same goes for Richie Tozier the
jokester now a disc jockey in LA played
by Bill Hader whom actor Finn wolfhard
named as his dream choice
rounding out the rest of the club Mike
Hanlon is now a librarian the only one
of the losers Club to remain in derry
nice played by Isaiah Mustafa the hunky
Old Spice guy billed n bro is now a
successful horror writer living in
England played by James McAvoy one of
the many examples of Stephen King
writing a version of himself into his
stories
then there's the anxious asthmatic Eddie
Cass Brack he now runs a limo rental
company in New York played by James
ransom and then there's Ben hence come
who's now been handsome he grew up to be
an architect and Nebraska he's played by
Jay Ryan and Stanley URIs is now an
accountant in Atlanta played by Andy
Beene we'll see if the movie ends up
keeping all these careers and locations
the same now chapter
two is set 27 years later with the kids
as adults returning to Derry to Rican
front it and reface the trauma that they
all buried as kids it returns to Derry
every 27 years to feed thus the
generational horrific incidents that
plagued dairies past but anyway back to
this scene with the elderly mrs. Kirsch
it's one of the most terrifying scenes
from a novel notice that the door plaque
still reads March subversion this in the
90s miniseries wind bed looks back down
at it it changes to Kersh but this is
all an illusion by Pennywise because
this home is actually abandoned the
marshes were the last residents of it
the wonderful bill skarsgård returns as
Pennywise in this movie and if you
listen closely missus Kirsch's voice
here is actually his voice on the door
first opens as she brings bed into this
home it's filled with creepy old
photographs which I stared at for way
too long it's interesting that Bev calls
this home cleaner because look in some
of the other shots mrs. Kirsch is
clearly a bit of a hoarder but Bev says
this because the last time she was in
this place the bathroom was soaked wall
to wall and ceiling with blood that
blood still stains the postcard that she
digs out of the hole in the wall this is
the same postcard that Ben gave her in
part one with his secret admirer poem
your hair is winter fire January embers
my heart burns there too
winter fire and January embers are
oxymoronic images that been used to
reflect Bev's warmth and strength in
this darkness that they all face but
let's move on to some more scary stuff
[Music]
okay in case elderly strangers don't
frighten you enough not because of any
ages reasons but all strangers are just
a bit strange
strange mrs. Kirsch does this wacky walk
out of frame in the background he right
but it's a dead giveaway that this is
actually penny wise who often moved in
the same inhuman way the director
machete is famous for this freaky
movement effect which she perfected in
his film on mama
mrs. Kirsch puts on this old record and
it took me forever but I figured out
that this song is a 1943 Danish song
called forgive my pronunciation even
though I'm like 50% Danish and I really
should be able to get this day a day
Scoon sa a vote again sorry but it
translates roughly to it is the most
beautiful thing I know by max Hansen now
I have no idea what these lyrics mean so
my Danish cousins watching this please
help me out but I will say that this
orchestration reminds me a lot of
midnight to the stars and you the now
creepy famous 1934 song that played at
the end of the shining there's just
something about old orchestra music that
really puts the Haunted housewives on
Bev notices these flies on the window
suggesting something is dead or rotten
in its place really should be her first
red flag to bounce followed shortly
after I miss curse saying the word die
as much as possible what are you still
doing here babe but notice how Bev gags
a little when she sits the tea book
readers know what this water turns into
but for the rest of you just know it's a
it's pretty gross and on to more
Christmas no one who dies here ever
really dies
but tell me how is it being back in dari
huh I gotta hand it to this actress for
nailing the delivery on this frozen
smile and her just shift back in a
chitchat like nothing happened but to
make it even more unnerving notice her
eyes there's a very subtle effect here
you might be just looking and looking at
this and still not even see it but each
eye is slightly focused in a different
direction her right eye is on Bev but
her left eye bulged out a little wider
is on us this is another Pennywise clue
remember the opening scene of part 1
when penny wise was in the sewer talking
to Georgie Bill skarsgård used this same
kind of trick with his eyes that he can
actually do though and that's scene it
was a lot more pronounced anyway on to
the next clip hi my father came to this
country with 14 dollars in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus okay here a brief
flash shows us that mrs. Curtis flash is
actually rotting under her clothes and
then she hurries off to the kitchen to
take cookies out of the oven which hints
at another detail for the book penny
wise is of course a shape-shifter the
embodiment of fear itself and it often
takes forms of childhood things that the
kids feared the most like for Richie
it's an old school clown but also a
werewolf and for Ben it's a money the
2017 movie didn't include the werewolf
or mummy scenes just little nods when
Pennywise briefly shape-shifts into them
late in the movie but in the book Beth
in addition to her deep trauma of her
father's abuse fears the witch from the
Hansel and Gretel story so in this scene
mrs. Kirsch briefly turns into that
witch her teeth turn into fangs her
cookies contain body parts but then her
transformation gets way darker related
to Bev's father which i think will
actually be the direction that this
movie goes instead of the witch here
mrs. Kirsch talks about how her father
came to this country with 14 dollars in
his pocket maybe I'm just reading too
much into it but the number 14 could be
significant think about at 7 and 7 7
kids to kill in chapter 1 7 adults to
kill in chapter 2 and then she says he
joined the circus bringing us to this
creepy history in the next clip
[Music]
okay for me the creepiest shot of this
entire trailer is mrs. Kirsh silently
peeking around the corner at Bev
no audio sting to call attention to it
just add a focus in the background
haunting us forever it actually reminds
me a lot of what I thought the creepiest
shot was in the first film that old lady
in the library
deep background out of focus behind been
turning to smile at him and never really
addressed by anyone I'm actually
wondering that Pennywise used these same
mrs. Kirsch form in that scene Bev looks
at this old photo of mrs. Kirsch as a
girl and her father the original penny
wise the dancing clown now in the book
this man is Bob gray Robert or Bob gray
was an early pseudonym for penny wise
and the name Bob gray showed up as an
easter egg in the first movie on that
bottle of alcohol but this movie isn't
like revising penny wises history he's
still an ancient evil entity the history
we're being presented here is just
another detail from the book it's a
false narrative that penny wise tells
Beverly in order to mess with her head
and bring up this father-daughter
connection in order to trigger her
memories of her own father actually
looking closely at this photo in
addition to the man's face may distorted
to look like Bill skarsgård as penny
wise the daughter kind of shares some
features with the face of Beth's father
Alvin Marsh played by Stephen boggarts
in the last movie the nose is different
but the eyes the mouth are kind of the
same I don't know maybe the little
girl's back in the past just looks like
adult men and then of course there's
mrs. Kirsch weird little dance across
the kitchen floor yes her nudity is
extremely unnerving here but it's really
all about Bev's sexual abuse from her
father penny wise is deliberately
triggering Bev's trauma and her
nightmares of her dad in order to get in
her head but on to the next clip
I was always daddy's little girl
what about you are you still his little
girl Beverly
are you okay Kirsch rushes at Bev and
the only thing I want to note here is
that the framing deliberately does not
show mrs. Kirsch is face suggesting that
the scariest element of this scene still
left a mystery will probably be pretty
shocking when we see the movie moving on
[Music]
I was gonna do this but you have to
stick together
okay this last section of the trailer
teases the rest of the film there's a
shot of the adult cast seeing their
reflected past selves as children when
they return to Derry they passed the
Barrens which is of course the town's
sewer drains that lead to its
underground lair you can also see shots
of various missing-persons fliers
reflecting its return 27 years later now
feasting on the next generation of Derry
residents the losers Club meets in this
Chinese restaurant which is another
well-known scene from the novel it ended
in a pretty shocking way bills seized
the hands of his brother Georgie with
his paper boat beckoning him to come
down to the sewer and then Mike Hanlon
leads them down the sewer pipes and then
there's a shot of Bill Hader as Ritchie
in the dairy town square reacting to
Pennywise floating overhead but notice
behind him here the townspeople are
weirdly frozen the cheerleaders pom-poms
are unmoving this is the same location
that Richie and the others talked about
it as kids in the first movie and Richie
revealed that clowns were his fear and
then he looked behind him at the stage
there was a cloud at gesturing toward
him and I think in that one shot that
clown was swapped in with Bill skarsgård
wearing a different costume so now
Richie is reliving that memory of his
first Pennywise sighting the production
on a stage behind him is the story of
Paul Bunyan just like the big statue
that Richie's facing that statue is a
nod by Stephen King to the real-life 31
foot tall statue of Paul Bunyan in
Bangor Maine Bangor claims to be Paul
Bunyan's birthplace and statues just a
bit creepy on to the last clip
[Music]
hello ok here you can see the adult Mike
with a slingshot which is a weapon that
the characters use against it in the
book actually if you watch the show
stranger things which also starts spin
wolfhard
the character lucas uses a slingshot
against the demagogue on which is one of
the many stephen king nods in that
series there's also this shot of like
hundreds of red balloons floating out
from under the bridge with a carnival in
the background this location is also
pretty significant from the book there
is one dairy resident named Adrian melon
who's a gay man who gets beaten up by
some homophobic kids and thrown off a
bridge on the way home from the carnival
below this bridge Pennywise finds him in
mutilates his body which the gang and
Adrian's boyfriend witness but this
clown sighting was covered up by the
prosecutors in the trial another shot
shows Mike looking up at Pennywise
jumping up from a vent on the wall doing
a little dance this building appears to
be burned ruins suggesting that this
could be the black spot the black dance
club in Derry that was burned down by
racists the kids actually past the black
spot in the first movie and Mike in
particular has this childhood trauma of
fire for this parents dying in a fire
then there's this shot of a man in
Pennywise Sal clown makeup but I don't
think this is penny wise rather this
could be Henry Bowers the sadistic bully
kid from the first movie whom penny wise
hypnotized remember Mike pushed him down
a well in the movie but in the book
Henry Bowers goes on to take the fall
for all of penny wisest murders and as
an adult it continues to puppet powers
against the losers Club in part two
but the insanity of the shot is hard to
look at I love the detail the paint
smeared onto the fingers which is a
similar makeup choice to what we saw
Heath Ledger do is the Joker in the Dark
Knight he was also a sadistic killer who
would have applied his own makeup so
they made sure to have paint caked on
his fingers in his fingernails there's
more shots of the loser's exploring its
underground lair and a don't Bev in a
blood as one does and then there's this
shot of them joining hands similar to
the final scene in part one Stephen King
who has admitted to using a lot of
cocaine when writing his books in the
80s goes to some really weird places in
part two of the book a lots of dealing
with them cosmic rituals and giant
turtles I will be really interested to
see if Chapter two even tries to adapt
that stuff but right at the end of this
trailer there is this tiny light which
Pennywise comes with his hands as a
young girl is drawn in this same light
appeared in first movie there
three of them deep inside penny wisest
mouth they're called the dead lights in
Kings novels a mere glance at a dead
light is supposed to cause death or
permanent insanity but when Bev looked
at them in the first movie she was just
merely hypnotized started floating then
had to kiss her to break her out of her
trance but the dead lights are the very
essence and true form of it they are
actually how the monster consumes
people's souls so by showing us the dead
light here in the trailer it looks like
this to become a major plot point in
part two comment down below with what
the scariest moment of this trailer was
for you follow me on instagram and on
twitter at EI vos it subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube for more
breakdowns of everything that you love
thank you for watching
by
[Music]